hello and welcome to the video playing
national master just wrong okay canada
let's let's play something a little bit
and all of the docs that be three line
against them against the French how does
that actually work I have actually have
no idea I have some idea about the
gambit lines it should be five min but
it doesn't make all that much sense if
you can yeah anyway come on let's go
make a big fuss out of it end play
quickly i miss you for him trying to
fight for control over you for ice is
getting an extremely nice diagonal here
a bishop won't be too looks very very
funny yeah definitely have to do
something about this Bishop rookie one
Bishop see bond and then try for some m
50
he has not cancelled yet yeah maybe he
wants to actually cancel non but I if he
castles short I wouldn't mind to play a
forward if i play a 4 immediately he
probably castles long and then tries to
do something against my king so I want
to be flexible here ok so now i actually
have a 3 NB floor as a potential idea
yeah that was it was kind of expected
what you doin if i move the night he
will certainly hit me with some G 5
business
even g5 immediately and bankroll style
is possible if I take though he will
take with the pawn and the G file opens
up okay yeah my dears after g5 to play
Knight h5 and I definitely will push it
on them the queenside myself g5 i play
Knight h5 just for blockade yo my name
isn't that easy for him let's see okay
so so he basically SAS taking on a five
isn't a big deal anyway I wanted to go
there so let's do it
taking on a five he might I could have
maybe done that yeah anyway let's not be
too sophisticated in this situation if I
take with the night here I'm covering g2
which is kind of nice maybe in this is
not bad I'm threatening also be five him
winning winning the house he does not
react to that ok I think I think I'll do
that it's not just the pawn I'm also
picking up g5 the answer would square
for the Queen yeah b5 is not a very
intuitive looking move but it is just
good for concrete reasons so let's see
how to how to end this now e six
something I need to probably take with
this and then have 60 h 2 ok but I can
take on this end with chick and I can
take with the pawn whoa I still should
have look at this wow wow ok that I
should have reconsidered Wow
ok
this is far more complicated than it was
necessary to be
he five and that was absolutely not
necessary it will open his queen up so
my idea is just to take on f5 okay that
that closes down the Queen 97 was my
intention let's do it
I just want to check open open this up
threatening here and you cringe you form
yeah unfortunately my only King
situation isn't ideal there's some f3
and things like that check so let's just
activate everything to the max and then
see what what good comes out of it maybe
can you go back just no King c8 just run
run away go in at five f6 as an
attacking idea here yeah maybe just
Kings the aid I don't don't know if i
have anything fantastic there get this
one I can do various things okay eight
works time morning and this also works
you think threaten include Queen f6 next
move
that looks technically extremely
vulnerable but not sure if I can really
exploit it here I'm just threatening
Luke e7
no let's um so rook is seven queen to d6
this as idea okay but he has no real
move I value if he takes Bishop F wall
and made on the aid it's kind of stuck
in yeah so Queen g51 check we need is on
time okay black for fits on time very
very unclear very unclear situation
around here I wasn't really sure what's
going on then computer is on roughly
equal which doesn't really tell you the
story of this position it's extremely
sharp I mean this does not work i think
probably okay taking on 85 is stronger
word and this is not bad i think it was
the wrong button this is should lose you
have to be five but I really gave him
yea it hit bit much I think this is okay
and now I should avoid e66 is just not
making any sense opening up this
diagonal yeah the computer is definitely
correctly and just strengthening the
position and maybe intending to take
their next and then then do all those
things he said yes the the night honor
the Queen on da it so black has no
sensible move and here this is getting
getting very weird yeah and okay he has
a good movie Bishop before wow wow
let's extremely strong Wow probably
losing yeah yeah the engine says I'm
losing now I didn't see that one here I
mean 97 okay it's not the best move but
it is leading to champion that is
manageable check this is troublesome
Queen sir King c7 is spent on you came
and cargo goopy aid this is very
difficult to defend oh he I Bishop f4
here this is this is also pretty awkward
okay so I didn't see why I just said
wind and then taking you now again but
this is also good right yeah it is did
wins as well chat range of not yeah yeah
I was basically deciding came winning
this on time and I didn't look look with
all that much yeah thats bad i am just
attacking him yeah the b3 line is not so
terrible and it is a bit a bit weird
line but if anything black should
probably should take and try to refute
it like that but this should be somewhat
okay for a while but i don't really know
how it works i mean this is this is make
some sense but all it's a very
unconventional position there k guys
thanks for watching